- [Voiceover] In order to
connect to the internet,
dedicated computers are
kept in a server room.
To prevent overheating,
the denisty of computers in a server room
must not exceed 2.1 computers
per cubic foot.
One meter is about 3.28 feet.
So they're converting linear meters
to linear feet.
They're not telling us how many
that one cubic meter,
they're not saying how many cubic feet
is one cubic meter.
So, I suspect we're going to have
to figure that out.
Which of the following densities
is equal to the maximum number
of computers per,
computers per cubic,
cubic,
cubic meter.
So how would we think about this?
Well, and if you're taking the SAT
you might not have time
to draw a nice diagram,
but this is literally
what I am visualizing in my head
when I first read that problem,
is I imagine a cubic meter.
I imagine a cubic meter
and along each of the three dimensions,
in the space we know of,
the three dimensional space,
a cubic meter,
we're going,
it's going to be one meter
in this dimension
by one meter in this dimension
by one meter in that dimension.
That's what a cubic meter is.
Now, one meter in this dimension,
that's going to be 3.28 feet.
So, maybe,
I'm not obviously drawing it perfectly,
but that's maybe a foot.
That's another foot,
actually I drew them too small.
That's a foot,
that's a foot
and that's a foot.
So you have one, two, three
and then a little bit,
a little more than a quarter of a foot.
So that's 3.28 feet
and then, let's see,
one foot,
two foot,
three foot.
Then you have one foot,
one foot,
two foot
and three foot.
And so a cubic foot will actually look
something like this.
A cubic foot would look
So, if you could put 2.1 computers
per cubic foot.
If you could put 2.1 computers
in this small cubic foot right over here,
surely you're going to
be able to put a lot more
than 2.1 computers in the cubic meter.
And just off of that,
you can rule out these two choices
because these two are less than 2.1.
But how would you actually calculate it?
Well, you could just multiply this volume,
a cubic meter,
you could just,
you can,
to figure out how many cubic feet it is,
you can just multiply by the dimensions
in terms of feet.
So this right here is
going to be 3.28 feet
in that dimension.
It's going to be 3.28 feet high
and it's going to be 3.28 feet,
I guess if we call this
dimension, maybe, deep.
And, so what's the volume right over here?
Well, it's going to be
3.28 times 3.28 times 3.28.
So the volume here is 3.28 to
the third power feet cubed.
Cubic feet
and this is how many cubic feet you have
per cubic meter
because this whole thing
is also a cubic meter.
Now, so this is the number of cubic feet
per cubic meter
and if you want to know how many computers
you can fit in that,
you can then just multiply by the density
and cubic feet.
So, times 2.1,
I'll write comp for computers,
computers per cubic feet.
And you can see that these units
are going to work out.
You have cubic feet divided by cubic feet
and if you multiply them
you're going to get
3.28 to the third power
times 2.1,
that's this times this,
computers,
computers per meters cubed
or per cubic meter.
So this is the maximum number of computers
per cubic meter, right over here.
Now, we could try to solve this by hand
or solve it someway,
but we can estimate it
because these two remaining choices
are quite different.
What's 3.28 to the third power
going to be, roughly?
Well, three to the third power is 27.
So this thing is going
to be larger than 27
and if you multiply
something larger than 27
by something larger than two,
you're going to get
something larger than 54.
So this thing is definitely
going to be larger,
way larger than 6.89.
And it's completely reasonable,
these numbers look right,
that 3.28 to the third power
times 2.1,
actually would be around 74.1.
And so this is definitely,
this is definitely the choice
that I would pick.
Now, if you had a lot of time
you could multiply this out,
use your calculator,
but based on these choices
you could actually just deduce
that this is going to be the right choice.
This choice is interesting
because if you look at it
this is,
this is kind of an answer to pick
if you forgot to convert to cubic,
if you forgot to convert
how many cubic feet
are per cubic meter
and if you just kept things
in linear meters and feet
because then you might say,
okay, if I have 2.1
computers per cubic foot
and then if you just say,
hey, well I have 3.28
as many feet per meter,
not thinking in terms of cubic feet
and cubic meters,
that if you take 2.1 times 3.28,
that's probably this choice here.
I haven't multiplied it out,
but that looks like 6.89.
So that's where this answer
actually came from.